un canular qui ne pèse donc pas auprès
de certains comme le député joachim
sound forge et le professeur thierry
lardeux noah et son collectif laissons
les médecins à prescrire
auteur d'un article dans la même revue
sur le même sujet écoutez nous on se
rend compte depuis le début que notre
opinion déranger et donc si notre
opinion dérange c'est qu'il ya des
soutiens pour défendre des thèses
adverse c'est tout donc moi au contraire
ça me conforte je me dis je me dis si
jamais ça dérange à ce point si jamais
il ya des gens qui ont du temps à perdre
pour essayer de discréditer une
hypothèse qui à mon avis est très
valable c'est que cette hypothèse est lé
plus sinon pourquoi perdre at il du
temps à la discréditer
pourquoi le publierai t-il dans des
revues pourquoi pourquoi autant de gens
s'acharnent aurait à nous harceler de
cette façon là c'est pas c'est pas
compréhensible donc c'est que
manifestement on dérange alors bon
pourquoi ça c'est pas à moi de répondre
à cette question et donc je pense que
cette condescendance le mépris de classe
de la part des coauteurs à se moquer
éperdument de gens qui sont des
scientifiques de pays en difficulté
juniors sert peut-être mauvais mais
franchement je trouve ça mais pousse au
sein d'un mépris et d'une et d'une
condescendance
c'est ça me sens bien ça me fait froid
dans le dos très franchement alors
évidemment la revue est pas très très
forte elle a certainement des revenus
heures de d'un niveau assez bas mais se
moquer des gens délibérément comme ça je
trouve ça assez vilain